تفاعلكم ينقلكم لاجواء احتفالات يوم
التاسيس وحقيقه فيديو سقوط بايدن عن سلم
طائرته في وارسو وادانت وزير مكافحه
المخدرات المكسيكي السابق والتهمه تهريب
المخدرات اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بصادف اليوم الثاني والعشرين من فبراير
مناسبه عزيزه على قلبي وقلوب كل السعوديين
وهي ذكرى يوم التاسيس قبل ثلاثه قرون التي
تم الاحتفال فيه لاول مره العام الماضي
هاشتاغات يوم التاسيس يوم بدينا متصدره
منصه تويتر اللي احتفلت في يوم التاسيس مع
السعوديين على طريقتها الخاصه فعملت حركه
لكل منهم داخل السعوديه وهي انه لما
يعملوا لايك على اي تغريده يتغير شكل
القلب حق علامه اللايك لشعار يوم التاسيس
مثل مو شايفين امامكم واحتفالا بيوم
التاسيس البلد مليانه بمختلف مناطقها
ومدنها فعاليات ثقافيه فنيه شعبيه غير
العروض الجويه طبعا والالعاب الناريه
وبيتضمن يوم التاسيس فعاليات ثقافيه فنيه
ايوه مجموعه اخرى المزيد او المزيد المزيد
من الف ونحن بنتكلم طبعا على الفعاليه في
مختلف المدن نحن خلينا نحن نروح للظهران
تحديدا من اثراء حيكون معنا الزميل عبد
الرحمن العصيمي اهلا فيك معانا عبد الرحمن
كل سنه وانت طيب اهلا وسهلا فيك وانت طيب
وانت بالف صحه وخير وسلامه يا رب اول شيء
احكي لي عن انت ايش لابس
انا اليوم متزين زي اجدادنا وابائنا لابس
الثوب
الطويله لابس طبعا الدقله ولابس المجند
هذا الزي المقاتلين قديما في المعارك لانه
في يكون في جزء من الرصاص او الخنجر او
ايضا السلاح وايضا لابس العقال المقصب هذه
العقال اللي كان يلبسوا اجدادنا والملك
عبد العزيز مؤسس الدوله السعوديه الثالثه
فيصل لكن بعد السبعينات تقريبا بدا يندثر
ثم عاد اكثر فاكثر مع الاحتفالات بيوم
التاسيس منذ العام الماضي في نسخته الاولى
طبعا احنا في مركز اثراء زي ما انت شايفه
يعني الناس والازياء الجميله معنى هذه
السيده الجميله اللابسه زي الوطني القديم
طبعا فوق راسها السره الاسم الكريم
زينه زينه زينه عارفين عن لبسك لابسه
اليوم طبعا
[موسيقى]
اي نعم طبعا هذه هذه اسمها البقشه
وهذا ثوب النشل برقع وهذا زي الشرقيه انا
حبيت اليوم اني اطلع بزي حلو وجميل يمثلنا
ويمثل السعوديه الشرقيه
كل عام وانتم بخير طبعا انت اسمك على اسم
برديوسر البرنامج
برافو عليك يا عبد الرحمن فعلا هي انبسطت
قالت اوه في على اسمي
طبعا اكيد لازم دحين تلاقيني ساره والسنه
بالضبط لازم تلاقيني
يلا اسمي كريم بلال طيب عرفيني عن لبسك
انت اليوم ايش لابسه اهل الشرقيه اللي هو
الدراعه
والكف ذهب والبرقع
كل عام وانتم بخير طبعا ساره حنا اليوم
معنا شاعر
يعطيني قصيده عصماء الاسم الكريم زياد بن
محمد فرحان مرزوق الحربي ونعم يا زياد انت
قلت لي عندي قصيده يلا اتفضل
انا مسلم يا مديح بلادي لكن يا موطني
ماذا اقول فيكم اسقطوا راسي من جعل البلاد
منارات لا تظلموا ماذا اقوله فيك اعظم
قبله يا قبله جمعت غيرك يقسمك ماذا اقول
وسيدي سليمان قد ساد البلاد كما يصيد
الهيثم صح لسانك
ما شاء الله كل عام وانتم بخير طبعا خلنا
بنكمل الجوله ساره معنا ايضا هنا غزلان
ولدتها برضه لبسهم وزيهم الجميل هذا
تكلمي غزلان اليوم كيف شفتي الاحتفالات
مبسوطه هنا مره مبسوطه وش لابسه اليوم
لابسه لبس
لبس قديم كل عام وانت بخير والله معنا
ايضا هنا اللبس حلو طبعا
طبعا تعريف جميل وبسيط ومختصر لبس قديم
معك كمان
لبس اهل الجنوب ولا
اليوم والاجواء هنا في اثراء
جايه مع العائله ومع اخوانك
ايضا معنا هنا احدى
الجميل ايضا مع الريحان اللي على الشعر
الراس وايضا السله القديمه هذا زي اي
منطقه منطقه عسير هذا يمثل منطقه عسير كيف
شايف الاجواء اليوم الاحتفالات الناس كثير
مره يسالوني هذا يمثل اي منطقه وانا منها
وكذا قعدت ايام الجاهزين اللوك هذا في بعض
جاهز من عند امي عند جدتي
تدوير الاغراض الوالده والجده
في استغلال يعني
الامهات والجدات استغلال عظيم اليوم لا لا
روعه روعه روعه
رائعه
كده واقفين مع بعض ولا هم دول اللي شفناهم
تكلمنا معاهم غزلان واصدقائها
يا ساره شوفي هذه يا ساره تعالي تعالي يا
قلبي ايوه هذه الواحده حكايه صار شايفه
كيف شايف الخدود يا ساره
ايش اسمها
شو اسمها
استفسار اسمع بسمه مش ساره انا عارف انك
تدورين عن ساره بس ما في ساره اليوم لا
تحاولين يا ساره
طبعا بس كم عمرها ما
شاء الله طبعا يعني بس ما عمرها سنه وجاي
اليوم محتفله مع اهلها لابسه اللبس الجميل
هذا يعني
اجواء رائعه صراحه بس
اجمل طفل اليوم في اثراء ولا لا ايش رايكم
متفقين معاي طبعا الجمهور كله يصوتنا
اليوم رائعه انت يا عبد الرحمن قول لي كان
في اعجاب باللوك حقك اخذك وقت وانت بتجهز
له كمان ولا برضو اعاده تدوير طبعا انا لا
طبعا انت عارفه ساره انا يعني دايما عندي
معجبين
فاليوم في
اعجاب خاصه اذا لاحظت العجائب يعني زي ما
انت شايف الحين عندنا هنا
يعني في ناس مقيمين في السعوديه
فروم تايوان
جميله وانيقه ايه
بالضبط بالضبط يعني زي ما حتى المقيمين
ناس من اوكرانيا ايضا المتحده الامريكيه
بريطانيا خاصه الموظفين الموجودين في
ارامكو المنطقه الشرقيه فكلهم جايين
يستمتعون ايضا بالاحتفالات والاجواء طيب
شكرا لك صراحه طبعا بسمه تفوز باللوك
الرائعه وطبعا بشكرك جدا كان معانا الزميل
عبد الرحمن عشان ما تزعل زينه
عبد الرحمن انت اليوم
راح تتصل عليك زينه وترسل لك هديه اكيد
على العموم انا بشكرك على الظهور معانا
طبعا اليوم ويعطيك العافيه وكل عام وانت
والسعوديه بالف الف خير كان معنا الزميل
عبد الرحمن العصيمي
امس زادت التفاصيل الدراميه من بعد ما
النشر الكسندر كمشان الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه السكك الحديديه الاوكرانيه عده
تغريدات كشف فيها عن بعض التفاصيل الجديده
فنشر في الاولى تغريده عنوانها بان هذه
قصه زياره الرئيس الامريكياب وكيف ولد
القطار الرئاسي وقال انه زياره بايدن كانت
لحظه تاريخيه وانه كان هو له الشرف هو وكل
فريقه انه عمله على تنسيقها وانها كانت
معقده جدا وكشف انه من اصل 24 ساعه بايضا
امضاء اكثر او امضى عشر ساعات بطريقه
الذهاب وعشر ساعات في الاياب يعني عشرين
ساعه في القطار واربع ساعات فقط في كييف
واعتذر للناس عن الخريطه اللي صارت او
الخربطه عفوا مشاهدينا عن اللي خربط اللي
صارت في جداول القطارات يومتها وقال انه
اضطروا ياجلوا رحلات عشان يتيحوا لقطار
بايدن السفر وانه لهذا السبب 90% بس من
قطارات هذاك اليوم
في وقتها المحدد وفق الجدول
بايدن بعض الزياره رجع وكمل زيارته لها
وكان له كلمه من هناك امس وفي لقطه عرضت
على تلفزيون بولندي من وصول طائره عامله
جدل فالناس تداولتها وقالت انها للحظه
سقوط اليم لبايدن من على سلم الطائره لكن
الحقيقه ان الفيديو
وانما لموظفه في البيت الابيض حتى ما تم
الكشف عن هويتها والمسكينه تعثرت واخذت
السلم كله على وشها
ناس كثيره بعد ما عرفت انه مو بايدن اللي
طاح قالت معلش يا جماعه اعذرونا بس بايدن
له تاريخ في الطيحات وتحديدا على سلالم
الطيارات وعشان كده افترضوا انه بايدن
[موسيقى]
بعد الزلزال والكلام عن اجسام مجهوله
والكائنات الفضائيه صار اي شيء غريب يجنن
العالم طبعا ويرعبهم والخبر اليوم من
اليابان اللي ظهر فجاه على احد شواطئها
الجسم كروي حديدي كبير وما حتفاهم
الجسم هذا شافته السيده على شاطئ ان شعله
المحيط الهادي وبلغت السلطات اللي جاءت
وطوقت المكان ومنعت اي احد يقترب وقفلت
الشاطئ يعني باختصار صارت حاله الطوارئ
لغايه ما يعرفوا ايش هي هذه الكره مستدعوا
خبراء متفجرات تتاكدوا لغم او شيء متفجر
او اداه تجسس صينيه او روسيه مثلا الخبراء
قالوا ان الكره قطرها متر ونصف وانها
جوفاء وما هي متفجره ولا شيء لكن الان مو
قادرين يحددوا ايش هي هل هي عوامه ارساء
طفت على سطح الماء ولا ايش بالضبط ما حد
قادر يعرف والدراما زادت لمن ظهر الرجال
وقال يا جماعه قلبتوا الدنيا اليوم عشان
الكوره ليش صار لها شهر على الشاطئ وما حد
عبرها ولا فحصها
امريكي كان يوم من الايام مرشح لي الرئاسه
ونافس
وكان كمان سنه اكثر من مره والان بيشغل
منصب سنه الولايه المهم المهم
نوصفها
بالمختلفه وهو نشط على المنصات وحساباته
شغاله على طول واليوم هو نجم تيك توك مو
بسبب حسابه اللي فاتحه على المنصه من
عشرين عشرين وعنده عليه مليون و400 الف
متابع وعشره ملايين لايك وانما اليوم منجم
على تيك توك بسبب فيديو طلع فيه بالغلط
خلينا نشوف المقطع
[موسيقى]
مثل عادي بتصور تيك توك في نيويورك
لكنه انتبهوا وطلع فورا من كادر الكاميرا
ولما ندقق طلع الشخص
وانتشر الفيديو والكل سريع علق عليه ويضحك
حتى البنت نفسها على حسابها شغاله كلها
على نفس الفيديو اللي من خمسه ثواني حولها
لنجمه هي كمان
من ابرز التعليقات انه هذا الفيديو بيعبر
عن شخصيه بيرني تماما والمقصود الشخصيه
اللي موسى لعن اي شيء وبتتصرف بتلقائيه
وردات فعلها حقيقيه والناس تذكرت وحده من
ابرز هذه اللقطات
واللي تحولت الى ميم ونعمل من نادي
منتجات ثانيه كثيره وقت ظهوره في حفل
تنصيب بايدن في 2021 جالس على واحده من
هذه الكراسي اللي بتنطوي ووقتها كان في
كورونا وتباعد وتعابير معبره جدا عن قدي
ايش هو مستمتع باللحظه وغير لابس القفازات
الشهيره هذا غير صوره وهو بيصور الحفل من
تلفونه وصور القفازات وقديش كبيره عليه
عموما في الفيديو الجديد هذا على تيك توك
اتضح ان النجم مو بس برنيسان ففي نسخه
اطول من الفيديو طرح فيها انه زوجت وكانت
طلعت قبل وخربت الفيديو اصلا معتذرات
وراها طلع اللي لحق نفسه وطلع من قدام
الكاميرا بس من بعد ما اعطانا نظره تحولت
هي كمان
[موسيقى]
لونا وزير الامن المكسيكي السابق معتقل في
امريكا بواجهه القضاء فيها في محاكمه لها
بادئه شهر ومداولتها استمرت ايام واليوم
اصدرت هيئه المحلفين قرارهم وادانو في
خمستهم حقيقه قضيه هذا الوزير ممكن
نعاونها حاميها حراميها فاللي كان وزير
الامن وبيقود حرب المكسيك على المخدرات
وتهريبها الامريكا ودين بتهم الفساد
وتهريب المخدرات ومنها تلقي ملايين
الدولارات لحمايه اكبر عصابه لتهريب
المخدرات في البلاد اللي هي كرتل سينالوا
هذه اللي كان رئيسها يعني طبعا شخصيه
معروفه جدا في عالم الاجرام والمخدرات
ومشاركه في الاتجار ب 53 طن من الكوكايين
من المكسيك لامريكا القضيه اثبتت بالادله
وبعد الاستماع لشهود منهم اعضاء معتقلين
من الكرتل واتضح انه الوزير السابق كان
بياخذ فلوس من العصابات مقابل تسهيل عملهم
وتهريب المخدرات بشكل امن وكانوا يبلغهم
باماكن تواجد الدوريات هذا الوزير السابق
الان وبعد ازانته بيواجه حكم ممكن يوصل
للسجن مدى الحياه والحكم منتظر انه يصدر
في 27 يونيو ويبدو انه كثير ناس يعني
منتظرين محاكمه والحكم عليه لانهم كانوا
متواجدين خارج المحكمه وجالسين حتى
بيطالبوا بمحاسبته بيتابعوا المحاكمه بشكل
دقيق وعلى فكره المجرمه المدان ما كان بس
وزير الامن السابق لكنه كان ايضا يوما مع
شرطي ومن ثم رئيس وكاله الاستخبارات
لمكافحه الفساد والجريمه المنظمه يعني
يعتبر اكبر مسؤول مكسيكي بيتحكم في القضاء
الامريكي في حرب ضد عصابات تهريب المخدرات
في امريكا الوسطى والجنوبيه واللي بتستغل
تواطئ وزراء محليين عشان تغرق امريكا
الشماليه بالمخدرات
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم انا
عود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله اليوم الربوع
صح يا جماعه بكره اجمل ايام الاسبوع
الخميس الونيس اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء
الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]